وبشان الاوضاع في خرسون قال الجيش
الاوكراني انه قتل عددا كبيرا من القوات
الروسيه ودمر مركز قياده في مقاطعه خرسون
وبث الجيش الاوكراني صورا تظهر اشتباكا
ليليا مسلحا على ضفاف احد الانهار قال
انها للعمليه العسكريه التي نفذتها احدى
مجموعاته في الجزء الخاضع للسيطره الروسيه
على الضفه الشرقيه لنهر النيبر جنوب شرقي
اوكرانيا
في المقابل قال الجيش الروسي انه سادف
مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه قرب جسر انطونوسكي
في خرسون واضاف الجيش الروسي انه احبط
محاولات هجوميه للقوات الاوكرانيه
واكد ان الطيران الحربي نفد ضربات على
اهداف اوكرانيه في خمسه اتجاهات ابرزها
بخموت ومارينكا وان المدفعيه الروسيه دمرت
مركز تجمع للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه